um the the eagles
continue their head coaching
interviews cowboys offensive coordinator
kellen moore
colts offensive coordinator nick ciriani
got interviews on tuesday dennis allen
the saints defensive coordinator we were
just saying the other day this guy can't
get a sniff he's getting a sniff good
from the philadelphia eagles he deserves
it i'm not saying he deserves a job but
at least talk to the guy their defense
has been really good the past few years
he's a former coach of the raiders and
don't hold that against him that he
didn't survive in a pit of dysfunction
right who could survive there yeah right
so
people are yeah so
look at all the names and uh you know
people continue to be fascinated by the
possibility of josh mcdaniels taking the
job i had tom curran on pft pm yesterday
and you know hey how many more times is
the window going to be open for mcdaniel
yeah that's right this could this could
be it this may be your opportunity to to
get a head coaching job because it may
not be in the offing in new england and
you may not be getting offers like you
used to if you stay there
assuming that they don't find another
franchise quarterback and who knows when
that's going to happen yeah no i mean
who does know it's great to see dennis
allen you know like you said get the
interview to me that would be the type
of guy he's the same you know a little
bit of the same version of josh
mcdaniels you know yeah okay younger guy
but not real young had the job before
was in a messed up situation in a lot of
ways but understands how to put together
an organization and a football team been
a part of it there with sean payton all
those things that that to me is the kind
of guy i i just if i was running the
eagles i would look at i don't you know
as much as hey kellen moore hey i know
you're going to be in this conversation
and nick siriani you're the offensive
genius guru guys we're going to hear
about your names next year and all that
i think to continue here but
uh the those
those type of guys to me don't match up
with like what philadelphia is trying to
do oh let me get a young inexperienced
coach and now have to deal with all
these issues on this team that
even an experienced coach would have a
hard time dealing with and we're going
to throw you in there and then we're
going to build for the future as we're
doing it and man you're gonna get
crapped on by the philadelphia media and
the fans all the time and it's gonna be
great hope you can deal with it young
inexperienced guy that to me is where i
don't see that i could be wrong and uh
but but i would rather have somebody
been there done that a little bit
there's two other dynamics here that i
think may be at play
one is that
you can pick brains of these guys yeah
so hey we know who we want right but why
not take advantage of this opportunity
to talk to all of these other guys and
in the process of talking to these guys
we may pick some things up that will
help us when we play the saints or the
cowboys or the colts or whoever in the
future that's a very real element to
these job interviews and al davis was
the master at that he talked to
everybody because it was an opportunity
to get information from anyone and
everyone who thought they were
interviewing for the job secondly and i
recall this happening and my god it's
been 10 years ago when the 49ers
initially hired trent bowkey as a gm and
reportedly he'll be the new gm in
jacksonville
he won kind of like a contest of
lightweights frankly i i don't mean that
he's the lightweight but you interview
other other people and it makes him look
good like maybe these uh maybe the idea
is that they've already locked onto a
josh mcdaniels or someone else and it
looks like they've done their due
diligence and right and this guy stands
out because look at all these other guys
we talked to it's not just we locked on
to one guy we've talked to all these
people and this guy's clearly our best
choice
i don't think that's a crazy thought i
think more than anything though your
first thought is probably more to the
truth you know the stealing of
information yes we get to know that on
certain teams you know the other thing
is just hey oh this is how you guys did
this oh well that's it show me let me
write that down we could probably apply
to that to our front office it's it's it
is it's the stealing of information in
totality about how teams prepare
how their draft boards whatever all set
up they're going to try to steal these
ideas certainly but they're going to do
their homework here they got
a very rare crazy situation and they
need to
take time to listen to coaches figure
out who's the right guy for the
situation
and probably ultimately listen to the
guy who has the best plan or plan of
attack to help them get out of where
they are right now um and uh
like i said like i said yesterday i
think josh mcdaniels would be the
perfect guy for that job
it it just uh
i was on wip yesterday afternoon
with john marks and ike reese and and i
tried to be
somewhat restrained in my
expression of opinions
but i i said in probably more tactful
language what i've said here who the
hell in their right mind would want that
job right now who wants to walk into
that i used my line that winning the
championship was like a taste of some
highly addictive drug and now they want
more and it's it's harder to operate in
that environment with a trophy in the
lobby it's not easier
and i just all the different factors all
the different things stirring around
thank you but i'll wait till next year
that continues to be my position well
and it could be that for mcdaniels there
is no next year maybe he knows this is
his chance this is the indiana jones
slide under the door reach back and grab
your hat because otherwise if you don't
do it now you're never getting through
that doorway i i think that's right but
i mean to me though the whole list is
like that
i feel like every coach on there has got
a little bit of a like uh well i don't
know todd bowles you've gotten it once
here do you want again dennis allen was
you had it once or wasn't that great do
you want it again you know hey kellen
moore you know nick siriani nobody else
is really interested in you so you're
pretty desperate to want this huh yeah i
mean i feel like the whole list is that
type of guy really where they have no
other option and they're going to look
at it and go wait do i want to deal with
this this might be my only option or i
go back to my old job
i don't know i just that's the sense i
get
well i was told over the weekend that
there's no timetable but don't be
surprised if it happens this week so
there's no timetable but don't be
surprised if it happens this week there
are two left
eagles
texans
just
wait just stay do the brian day ball and
stay
where you are
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports